so looking back now from the all the
pieces of data you've integrated
you've personally added what do you
think it could be
i don't know i don't know what it could
be i think we've been able to categorize
it successfully into a few buckets
we've been able to say that you know
this could be u.s technology that
someone
put in the wrong piece of sky or you
know perhaps was developed and tested an
inappropriate spot by someone that
wasn't paying best practices is there uh
sorry to interrupt is there
a sort of modularity to the way
the the military operates to where it's
possible for one branch not to know
about the tests of another yeah i think
it's perfectly reasonable to think that
that could occur right and so if we just
make that assumption we can integrate
that into our analysis here and just say
okay but at the point we're at now you
know we have to assume that that's not
the case right with everything that's
been going on and the statements have
been made and the hearings
i think that if it was a
a non-communication issue
we're in big trouble at this point
what about it being an object from
another nation from china from russia or
even one of our allies perhaps right
maybe
you know
i don't think it's
um controversial to say that our allies
could be gathering information about us
or anything of that nature but that
would be an extreme case but i think
it's just important to say right to not
just say russia or china and just call
them the bad guys and assume that if
they don't have it no one can do it um
and so from my perspective you know
anyone else anyone else and it doesn't
necessarily need to be a foreign power
it could be a non-government entity
perhaps although i think that's very
unlikely but again these are these are
things you must consider if you kind of
throw everything
everything other than the us under under
scrutiny
but you know from what
has been reported and the behaviors that
have been seen it would be
i would expect to see remnants of that
technology
elsewhere in the economy
there seems to be too many
things that require
advanced technology that would be
beneficial commercially as well as in
other military applications for it to be
completely locked away by
one of our competitors now i could see
us perhaps locking something away if
we're already in the lead and having it
to
pull out as needed but for someone
that's perhaps in a power struggle and
they're in second place
they might be more aggressive with the
development of different types of
technology willing to accept bigger
risks
do you think it could be natural
phenomena that we don't yet understand
i think that there are a number of
things that this is going to be right i
don't think there's one thing at the end
of the day but i certainly think that
that is part of what some of this could
be i don't think it's what we were
seeing on the east coast uh and i don't
think it is related to the roosevelt
incident or i'll even go out and say the
nimitz incident but what's the roosevelt
incident the roosevelt incident
typically referred to as the gimbal
and or the go fast video and then the
nimitz is from uh
with the david fravor has uh witnessed
directly and spoken about
we'll talk about that as well i'd just
love to get your um
your sort of uh interpretation of those
incidents but
yeah so in this particular case natural
phenomena could be a part of the picture
but you're saying not the whole picture
yes
yes and we can't discount it
oh the other thing is what about the
failure of
pilot eyesight
like sort of
some deep mixture of actual direct
vision
human vision system failure
and like psychology
like
um seeing something weird
and then filling in the gaps
because in order to make sense of the
weird i've tried to expose myself to
a scenarios like that that i don't
necessarily think are right but i've
explored them to see if they could have
some truth and one example is let's
imagine a scenario where if we're seeing
these objects every day off the east
coast
i can imagine a technology or an
operation where you had some type of
traditional propulsion system operating
drones in order to gather data like we
had discussed
and
i could i could envision a clever enough
adversary that could perhaps destroy or
somehow remove these objects and replace
them with new objects essentially when
we're not looking right and that
accounts for the
large uh airborne time and so i i
explore options like that and i try to
see you know what what evidence and
assumptions need to be made in order to
prove or disprove that and you know
you would need so much infrastructure
you know you need some you need so many
assets and so i try to explore some of
those fallacies and some of those
concerns and as aviators we're trained
into many uh like actual physical like
eyesight and kind of illusion
training so like at nighttime flying
there's so many things that can happen
flying with false horizons and so we
receive hours of of training on that
type of of stuff but
this just falls outside the category
from my perspective what was the
visibility conditions when in the times
when people were able to see it and are
we
we just earlier discussed complete
nighttime
darkness
[Music]
in this case was was it during the day
it was a perfectly clear day that that
particular incident yep
in a world that's full of mystery i have
to ask what do you think
is the possibility that
it's not of this earth origin
i like the term non-human intelligence
in a sense
because
again
there's so much there's a lot of
assumptions in there that
may cause us go down the wrong roads
it could you know these could be
something that our weather phenomena of
earth right or something else that is
just something we don't understand or
can't imagine right now that's still of
this earth
um
if we consider
extraterrestrials or something that came
from a physical place far away in space
time
you know that leads us to some detection
assumptions that we would need to make
and so i just try to not categorize it
under anything and just say hey is this
demonstrating intelligence
and start from there as a single object
what can we learn about it kinematically
how it's performing what does that mean
for its energy source what does that
mean for the g-forces inside
and then step it out a level and say
okay how are these interacting with our
fighters if they are how are they
interacting with the weather and their
environment how are they interacting
with each other so can we look at these
and how they're acting perhaps as a
swarm
uh especially off the east coast where
this happening all the time with
multiple objects right and so we might
be able to determine some things about
their maybe you know center capabilities
or the areas of focus you know if we can
determine uh how they're working in
conjunction with each other but you know
seeing one little flash of an object
doesn't provide that type of insight
but we have the systems4 but and it's
kind of made on irony but it's it's a
fact of life the reality that many of
these well-deployed highly capable
systems are held under the military
umbrella which makes it difficult to
provide that data for scientific
analysis
so there's probably a lot more data on
these objects that's not being
that's not made available probably even
within the military for analysis i think
so yeah i think there's a lot of data
that could be made available
and you know that's one of the reasons
why
you know i've been engaged with the
american institute of aeronautics and
astronautics to build you know a large
resources of cross-domain expertise so
that if or when that data is available
or that there's additional analysis
needed you know we can spin up those
teams and make that analysis
you